Michael's the most amazing filler beef
wellington it's the rolls-royce cut
first off season top and bottom go into
the pan every 15 seconds we're moving
around osso bucco that's my main course
rating that he's not about minutes it's
about the color cooking is all about
touching cooking is about smelling very
carefully we go round almost like a
Swiss roll that's your favorite isn't it
Swiss roll that's right your mother
hello needs to mean that we you spoke to
my mum I don't know did you phone my mom
yeah before shaving yeah I did cuz I
said they're usually quite bossy I said
what's the best way to handle him and
she said just treat him like a little
boy with lots of love but firmness Larry
help me justice get on
I think he's impossible to ever
Christmas without sprats yeah
shaking their potatoes look at that
here's the magical bit every time even
still now after cooking for nearly 30
years
look Jerry that means is it red that is
pink that is beautiful so you can't do
it a little bit more I'm just thinking
not everybody likes that color yeah why
you some awkward I found you because I
wanted some help I don't need a [ __ ]
butt plug at my ass telling me I can't
do it I think now mush
we got the gravy this is how you make
osso bucco let's do it
[Music]
it's the first time is there a girl in
10 years how's your sauce from sausage
rah
please don't do that I'm gonna tell your
mother stop listen and listen carefully
it needs to be in your mind Jerry when
it's brown it's cooked when it's black
it's [ __ ] nose hair the team behind I
don't think they understand the menu
100% and I don't think they're realizing
how difficult the menu is see Brava
maybe you can do it probably team worker
now is thinking oh my god I think Gina
was right I saw him looking at my dishes
and thinking we shall Batman sir Jerry
what you doing you can't lick the spoon
to put a spoon back in this hajime in
law so no no very nice give me the
Victoria Beckham's number please
oh my god let's get a proper spice girl
in here you're right like a knife my
heart